♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT" THE
HALLMARK OF ANY AUTHORITARIAN
VIRGINIAN'S POLITICIZED JUSTICE
UNDER THAT YOUR OPPONENTS GO TO
JAIL AND HER SUPPORTERS CAN DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT.
THIS REVEALED TO THE STATE NOT
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
IT, BUT TO DISSENT.
WE'VE REACHED A POINT ANYWHERE
NEAR THAT HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES IS OR SOMETHING
WORSE THAN THAT FOR SCARIER OR
HARDER TO FIX, BUT IN FACT WE
HAVE REACHED THAT POINT US WHERE
WE ARE.
YESTERDAY FOR EXAMPLE A MAN
LEAPED ON STAGE AT A CAMPAIGN
EVENT AND TRY TO STAB.
A SITTING MEMBER OF CONGRESS IS
CHALLENGING KATHY AND THE
GOVERNORS RACE IN NEW YORK.
IT'S ORDINARILY ATTEMPTING TO
ASSASSINATE A FEDERAL OFFICER
WOULD BE CONSIDERED A BIG DEAL,
BUT THE REPUBLICANS SO IT'S NOT
A BIG DEAL ANYMORE.
THE MAN WHO TRIED TO MURDER WAS
RELEASED IMMEDIATELY WITH NO
BAIL.
LESS THAN 24 HOURS LATER BY
CONTRAST FROM HER TRIPADVISOR
BANNON WAS CONVICTED OF CRIMES
RECENTLY THAT WERE CRIMES AT
ALL.
FOR WHICH HE NOW FACES A PRISON
TERM OF TWO YEARS.
HE HAS BEEN DECLARED GUILTY OF
SOME AND CALLED CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS.
MY STRIKE HE WAS AN
UNINTENTIONALLY HILARIOUS TERM
SINCE MOST THE TIME CONGRESS
INVITES CONTEMPTS.
THE POINT IS THIS IS A CRIME THE
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT CONVICTED OF
EVER.
ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC HOLDER NRS
EXECUTIVE OR ONCE FOUND TO BE IN
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS OF BOTH OF
THEM AND FOR REAL CRIMES IT WAS
IN MEXICO.
IT WAS TARGETING CONSERVATIVES
OR AUDITS ANOTHER ONE WENT TO
TRIAL HE CLAIMED EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE IT WAS ENOUGH EVEN
AFTER A JUDGE RULED EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE IT DID NOT APPLY BUT
IT DIDN'T MATTER HE WALKED.
LOIS CITED THE FIFTH AMENDMENT
IT WAS SIMPLE AS THAT.
BOTH OF THEM TODAY ARE FREE AND
RICHER THAN EVER.
THESE STANDARDS DO NOT APPLY TO
STEVE BANNON STEVE BANNON WAS
SUBPOENAED BY THE JANUARY 6
COMMITTEE DESPITE THE FACT THAT
HE HAD LITERALLY NOTHING TO DO A
JANUARY 6.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE HE LEFT THE
WHITE HOUSE THREE YEARS OF
BEFORE IT HAPPENED.
IT DIDN'T MATTER HE ANNOYED THE
WRONG PEOPLE SO HE IS GOING TO
JAIL.
THIS SHOULDN'T SURPRISE YOU
REALLY BECAUSE YOU WERE BUILDING
TOWARD THIS MOMENT FOR SOME
TIME.
YOU MIGHT RECALL GREG DEBBIE
BARACK OBAMA'S FORMER
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL HE WAS
ACQUITTED OF VIOLATING THE
FOREIGN AGENTS ADMINISTRATION
BACK IN 2018 EVEN WORKING FOR
UKRAINE.
NOW ALMOST AT THE SAME MOMENT IT
WAS CONVICTED OF VIOLATING THE
SAME LAW.
ON THE SAME ACCOUNT FOR UKRAINE.
HOW DOES THAT WORK EXACTLY?
IT SEEMS A GOOD DOUBLE STANDARD
AND IS A DOUBLE STANDARD BUT
IT'S A CONSISTENT STANDARD BE
SEEN AGAIN AND AGAIN.
FOR MICHAEL SUSSMAN WHO JUST
ACQUITTED OF LYING TO THE FBI
THAT HAPPENED IN MAY THAT THEORY
WAS THAT REALLY WHO KNOWS WHAT
MICHAEL TOLD THE FBI ABOUT
NONEXISTENT SERVICE FROM TOWER.
OKAY.
AS LONG AS WERE USING THAT
THEORY DOES IT WORK FOR
EVERYONE?
WILL DIDN'T WORK FOR MICHAEL
FLYNN ON THE OTHER HAND UP TO OF
THOSE HAD THOSE KEY CARD FBI
HEADQUARTERS LIKE MICHAEL
SUSSMAN DID AND I CAME IN HANDY
THAT RELATIONSHIP.
BUT HE DIDN'T HAVE THAT
RELATIONSHIP IT WAS DESTROYED.
BECAUSE HANDWRITTEN NOTES TO
PETER STRZOK WHICH YOU CAN NOW
SEE ON MSNBC THE CONVERSATION OF
THE WHITE HOUSE OF RUSSIAN
SANCTIONS.
GET HIM TO LIE AHEAD OF
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE THEY WROTE
SPEAKING OF FLYNN.
SO ON THE BASIS OF THAT SET UP
THEY HOUNDED MIKE FLYNN AND THE
POVERTY THE SAME THING HAPPEN TO
GEORGE.
HIS CRIME?
NOT BEING AS FORTHCOMING AS
POSSIBLE ABOUT HIS JOB STATUS
WITH THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN UNPAID
THAT'S WHAT HE TOLD THE COURT
AND A FILING.
THE DEFENDANT DID NOT PROVIDE
SUBSTANTIAL ASSISTANCE OF THAT
IS THE STANDARD?
SO HE WENT TO PRISON.
SO TO THE 69-YEAR-OLD
GRANDMOTHER CALLED PAM HEMPFIELD
IS CURRENTLY SERVING A 12 MONTH
IN FEDERAL PRISON BECAUSE SHE
PARADED IN CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6
IT DIDN'T HURT ANYONE SHE JUST
GOT BREAST CANCER SHE'S GOING TO
PRISON.
ADJUST FROM WASHINGTON HAD NO
PROBLEM ISSUING THAT SENTENCE
EXACTLY THE SAME MOMENT THE
ATTORNEY FOR D.C. DROPPED ALL
CHARGES AGAINST
STEPHEN COLBERT'S PRODUCTION
CREW FOR DOING THE SAME THING,
BUT WORSE.
SO STEPHEN COLBERT'S TEAM MAY
HAVE LIED TO FEDERAL AUTHORITIES
WHEN THEY COULD BE IN A
RESTRICTED AREA, BUT THEY DIDN'T
LIED TO FEDERAL AUTHORITIES IN
QUITE THE SAME WAY APPARENTLY.
AND OF COURSE THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT POLITICS UNLIKE
ROGER STONE HIT A THREE YEAR
PRISON SENTENCE HE HAD A
S.W.A.T. TEAM COME WITH THE CNM
CREW TIPPED OFF BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FOR MAXIMUM
HUMILIATION WHAT WAS HIS CRIME
QUESTION ARE KNOWN COULD
REMEMBER THERE WASN'T ONE.
SO IF YOU BEEN PAYING ANY
ATTENTION AT ALL TOWARD JUSTICE
SYSTEM PARTICULARLY READ SOME
SENSE OF WHERE THIS WAS GOING.
IT WAS MOVING TOWARDS THE
AUTHORITARIAN SYSTEM WE HAVE
FOUR JUSTICES OFFENDED PEOPLE IN
CHARGE GET PUNISHED SUPPORT THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE AND DO WHATEVER
YOU WANT.
STILL EVEN KNOWING THAT TODAY'S
CONVICTION OF STEVE BANNON IS AN
ESCALATION WASN'T EVEN A
PRETENSE IN THE TRIAL THAT MEAN
SELECTIVE PROSECUTION IS NOT
ALLOWED SINCE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
IF YOU DON'T TRY ONE PERSON FOR
A CRIME YOU DON'T GET TO CHURCH
ANOTHER PERSON FOR THE SAME
CRIME BECAUSE THAT IS SELECTIVE
IT'S POLITICAL.
BRENDA GARLAND THAT'S A NEW
RULE.
OFFEND US AND GO TO JAIL.
SOME PERMITTED TO SAY THE
COUNCIL IS AGAINST SPENDING
AGAINST A JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE
YOU COULD EVEN SAY THAT.
THEY ALLOWED TO ARGUE THE
SUBPOENA WAS A LEGALLY INVALID
COULD YOU ARGUE THAT?
ALL STEVE BANNON WAS ALLOWED TO
DO WAS SHUT UP YET REMAIN SOUND
AND AWAIT HIS CONVICTION AND
THAT'S WHAT HE DID.
OUTSIDE OF FEDERAL COURT TODAY
THEY POINTED OUT THAT THE
SUBPOENA MEMBERS OF THE
JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE TO TESTIFY
AT HIS TRIAL.
WHY CAN'T YOU FACE YOUR IS NOT
GUARANTEED UNDER OUR SYSTEM?
NOT IN THIS CASE.
HAVING THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SHOW UP WOULD THE ONE
THING THAT THEY CANNOT TOLERATE
JUST CROSS-EXAMINATION JUST
WATCH.
THE JUDGE PARTICULAR THE CODE OF
ADMINISTRATION HERE EVERYBODY I
ONLY HAVE DISAPPOINTMENT.
THAT IS THE GUTLESS MEMBERS THAT
SHOW TRIAL COMMITTEE.
>> Tucker: DID YOU EXPECT THEM
TO SHOW UP?
THEY DON'T HAVE TO TESTIFY.
DON'T HAVE TO DO ANYTHING THEY
DON'T WANT TO DO.
THEY COULD SEND THEIR ENEMIES TO
JAIL SO THEIR BEHAVIOR IS REALLY
NOT THAT SURPRISING.
THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE ITSELF
DOES NOT ALLY ALLOW
CROSS-EXAMINATION.
DURING HIS HEARINGS HE MAY HAVE
NOTICED THIS.
IT IS EVEN ALLOW FOR THE
EDIFICATION OF MANY WITNESSES
THAT WERE IN HONESTLY.
HOW DO YOU DO SHOW TRIALS?
AS HE DO A SHOW TRIAL.
THESE AREN'T HEARINGS IN ANY
RECOGNIZABLE SENSE.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT IT IS THE
COMMIT DOES NOT ALLOW THE
CROSS-EXAMINATION OF FORMER
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON FOR EXAMPLE
EVEN AFTER SHE MADE CLAIMS THAT
WERE INSANE THEY MADE NO SENSE.
SHE CLAIMED THAT DONALD TRUMP
TRY TO CARJACK HIS OWN LIMO AND
TRAVELED TO THE CAPITAL.
SO SHE HAD BEEN CROSS-EXAMINED.
NOT THE WOKE SYSTEM OF JUSTICE
LIZ CHENEY HAS BROUGHT US BUT
THE CONVENTIONAL SYSTEM YOU HAVE
A CROSS-EXAMINATION THAT SOMEONE
MIGHT'VE POINTED OUT
SECRET SERVICE AGENTS DENIED HER
ACCOUNT BUT IF YOU'RE WATCHING
ON MSNBC OR CNN WOULD TAKE IN
THIS PROPAGANDA LIVE THEN
BRAGGED ABOUT IT WERE DOING THE
BIDDING OF THE STATE WERE SO
PROUD OF HER CALLING A
JOURNALISM.
WE REFUSE TO DO THAT BECAUSE WE
HAVE DIGNITY AND WHEN OUTLIERS
BUT IF YOU'RE WATCHING US ON
THOSE CHANNELS YOU HAVE NO IDEA
THE SECRET SERVICE DENIES THIS
ACCOUNT THE SECRET SERVICE WAS
NEVER CONTACTED BY LIZ CHENEY OR
ADAM KINZINGER BEFORE TESTIMONY
AND THAT'S BIZARRE.
BECAUSE OF THE COMMITTEE WANTED
TO GET TO THE TRUTH OF THE TRUMP
GRABBED THE WHEEL OF THE LIMO IF
THEY WANT TO TALK TO PEOPLE WHO
WERE THERE BUT THEY DIDN'T.
REPUBLICANS IF THEY BEEN ALLOWED
TO CROSS-EXAMINE IF THEY
DEMANDED TO PROSECUTE
CROSS-EXAMINE ROUTE DEFENDING
REPUBLICANS THEY FALLEN DOWN ON
THE JOB THAT'S AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
IF SOMEONE HAD BEEN ALLOWED TO
ASK ADULT QUESTIONS OF THE
WITNESS WE MIGHT HAVE LEARNED
WHAT CNN VIEWERS WILL NEVER KNOW
AND THAT'S THAT THEY REPORTEDLY
TRY TO GET A JOB AFTERWARDS.
BUT NONE OF THAT WAS ALLOWED.
THIS IS PURE PROPAGANDA IS GOING
ON FOR MONTHS.
LAST NIGHT THE JANUARY 6
COMMITTEE FROM AN ANONYMOUS
OFFICIAL CAN YOU IMAGINE AN
ANONYMOUS OFFICIAL?
CLAIMING THAT SECRET SERVICE
AGENTS ASSIGNED TO MIKE PENCE
WERE USING THE RADIOS TO TELL
HER FAMILIES GOODBYE LIKE
THEY'RE IN THE DECK TITANIC.
THAT THEY WOULD DIE IN THE
CAPITAL BECAUSE SOME GUY
INVITING HORNS ON MUSHROOMS WAS
SPINNING AROUND IN CIRCLES AND
TALK PEACE.
THERE WERE SO AFRAID WHAT'S THIS
NONSENSE.
>> MEMBERS AT THIS TIME WERE
STARTING TO FEAR FOR THEIR OWN
LIVES.
THERE WAS A LOT OF YELLING AUTO
VERY PERSONAL CALLS OVER THE
RADIO.
I DON'T LIKE TALKING ABOUT IT.
THERE WERE CALLS TO SAY GOODBYE
FAMILY MEMBERS.
FOR WHATEVER THE REASON WAS ON
THE GROUND THEY THOUGHT THAT
THIS WAS GONNA GET REALLY
INTERESTING.
>> Tucker: IT'S ABSOLUTELY
SHAMEFUL ABSOLUTELY SPAIN
SHAMEFUL THAT THEY PLAYED THIS.
WITHOUT PUSHING BACK IN EVEN THE
MILDEST WAY.
I WOULD SEE NEWS, IT'S NOT NEWS
AND YOUR JOB IN JOURNALISM IS TO
HOLD THE POWER PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE IS NOT TO DO THEIR
BIDDING FOR THEIR LIVES ON TV ON
EDITED IN PRIME TIME.
IT'S WHAT EVERY OTHER CHANNEL
HAS DONE EXCEPT FOX NEWS AND WE
ARE PROUD OF THAT.
YOU SHOULD BE ASHAMED YES.
YES YOU SHOULD BE ASHAMED.
THERE IS NO CROSS-EXAMINATION
ALLOWED IN ANY OF THIS BECAUSE
THIS COMMITTEE WOULD NOT ALLOW
IT.
NO REBUTTAL OF ANY KIND.
SO OF COURSE IT WAS NO INQUIRY
ABOUT WHY A POLICE OFFICER WITH
A DOCUMENTED HISTORY OF
RECKLESSLY MISHANDLING FIREARMS
SHOT AN UNARMED WOMAN IN THE
NECK AND AIR FORCE VETERAN.
HE SHOT HER IN THE NECK.
WHY?
WHEN ALLOWED TO ASK.
WHAT I'M TO THE THOUSANDS OF
HOURS OF SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE
WHY CAN WE SEE THOSE?
NO YOU'RE NOT EVEN ALLOWED TO
ASK WHY WE CAN EVEN SEE THOSE.
WE CAN'T KNOW WHY POLICE ARE ON
VIDEO LETTING PEOPLE INTO THE
CAPITAL COMPLEX ON JANUARY 6.
WHY IS THAT?
NOT ALLOWED TO ASK.
THIS IS GOOD TO CONTINUE ADAM
SAID THAT THIS CHARADE WHICH
REALLY DOES CORRODE THE HEART OF
OUR SYSTEM THIS WILL CONTINUE
ALL THE WAY UNTIL THE MIDTERMS
BECAUSE HE IS DUMB ENOUGH TO SAY
THE ACQUIRED OUT LOUD ADMITTED
AS A POLITICAL EXERCISE COME ON.
SPEAK OUT THIS INVESTIGATION IS
NOT WINDING DOWN WE MAY BE
TOWARDS THE EGGS OF THIS CRUNCH
OF HEARINGS, WE MAY HAVE MORE
HEARINGS IN THE FUTURE AND THE
INVESTIGATION IS STILL ONGOING
SO WE ARE GETTING TO THE BOTTOM
OF WHAT WE NEED TO KNOW.
>> Tucker: WERE GETTING TO THE
BOTTOM ACTUALLY YOU ARE
PREVENTING LEGITIMATE OBVIOUS
QUESTIONS FROM BEING ASKED.
I JUST THE POINT OF FACT HOW
LONG THESE HEARINGS GO ON THEY
COULD GO ON FOREVER AND
ADAM KINZINGER WILL BE A SAD
TORMENTED TINY MAN WITH A
MEASURABLE PERSONAL LIFE THAT
SOME COMFORT.
THE PROSECUTORS HERE WORKING FOR
THEM AND CHENEY AND THE REST OF
THIS COMMITTEE JUST LIKE THE
SCHOOL BOARDS AND TEACHERS FROM
LAST YEAR THEY WORKED IN TANDEM
WITH THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO
PUNISH THE ENEMIES OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WHAT IS